un bonsoir à tous et bienvenue pour deux
heures d'émission nous décrypterons
comme chaque soir du lundi au jeudi
l'essentiel de l'information avec nos
invités et nos reporters sur le terrain
voici les grands titres de l'actualité
de ce lundi 23 novembre une prise de
parole attendue celle d' emmanuel macron
ce mardi à 20h alors que les contraintes
liées aux kovy pèsent sur l'économie et
le moral des français
des mesures concrètes d'allègement sont
espérés comme la réouverture des
commerces autour du 1er décembre
la décision sur une éventuelle ouverture
des stations ski à noël sera telle prise
dans les dix prochains jours selon
matignon
joe biden commence à dévoiler ses
premiers choix pour le futur
gouvernement américain avec anthony
blinken la diplomatie john kerry
représentant spécial pour le climat et
pour la première fois un hispanique
alejandro mayorkas ce la sécurité
intérieure donald louis poursuit ses
recours en justice pour tenter
d'inverser la tendance du scrutin
présidentiel
depuis dimanche le retrait des
etats-unis du traité international ciel
ouvert est officiel six mois après que
le locataire de la maison blanche l'a
dénoncé
[Musique]
c'est donc une allocution télévisée très
attendue le chef de l'état présentera
demain la stratégie sanitaire de la
france pour les mois à venir nous
retrouvons tout de suite notre reporter
baisse chez lui en direct de l'elysée
bonsoir bassem
alors quelle mesure peut-on attendre
demain
effectivement stéphanie vous l'avez dit
c'est demain que le chef de l'état à 20h
prendra elle la parole pour revenir sur
ce confinement ce confinement de la
deuxième vague du coronavirus des
annonces très attendues notamment sur
les mesures qui englobe cette deuxième
vague il n'y aura pas de déconfinement
en tout cas c'est ce que laisse entendre
le gouvernement pas de déconfinement
mais plutôt un assouplissement du
confinement actuelle un assouplissement
qui se fera normalement en trois temps à
partir de début décembre on pourrait
revoir la ouverture des commerces à
partir du 18 décembre on pourra
normalement circuler sans attestation
épis à partir de janvier on pourrait
laisser voir les différents districts
turquie étaient fermés à savoir les bars
les restaurants les cinémas les salles
de concerts etc
et puis concernant bien sûr les vacances
de noël et puis les stations ski dans
une dizaine de jours le gouvernement
devrait prendre une décision quant à une
réouverture ou non des stations de ski
c'est une allocution qui aura lieu à
partir de demain dans un contexte assez
particulier malgré une évolution
positive de la situation sanitaire le
message du gouvernement de fixer un cap
et réussir un déconfinement tout en
réduisant bien sûr les incertitudes des
français concernant cette deuxième vague
concernant toutes ces mesures prises par
le gouvernement l'objectif du chef de
l'état a laissé entendre qu'il
souhaiterait que des français puissent
passer noël en famille et éviter coûte
que coûte une troisième vague du
coronavirus qui serait lié bien sûr à
ses vacances de noël cette prise de
parole à partir de demain du chef de
l'état bien sûr elle va se faire dans un
contexte économique social politique et
sanitaire assez tendue en france je vous
rappelle qu'il ya eu pas mal de
manifestations concernant cette loi
sécurité globale ce texte qui doit être
voté normalement demain à l'assemblée
nationale et puis bien sûr décrites
des critiques de la part de la classe
politique concernant emmanuel macron qui
déclare que c'est des décisions prises
par un seul homme voilà le contexte dans
lequel le chef de l'état devrait
intervenir à partir de demain
côté opposition bien sûr ils ont en
profité pour critiquer le gouvernement
et mettre le doigt sur l'augmentation de
la pauvreté depuis le début de la crise
je coronavirus à savoir sur ces deux
vagues c'est surtout est la droite qui
en a profité pour critiquer le
gouvernement et critiqué emmanuel macron
sur l'ensemble de son mandat voilà ce
qu'on pouvait dire à la veille de cette
allocution du chef de l'état demain à 20
heures concernant les décisions prises
par rapport au confinement actuelle
merci ben hassen chébili en direct donc
de l'elysée à la veille de cette
allocution à des manuels micron alors
sur ne peut pas encore parler
vous l'avez dit vsn de déconfinement
cette prise de parole pourrait donner un
peu de baume au coeur aux français avec
des allègements annoncé qu'ils ne
pourront toutefois concerner tout le
monde
pour parler de ce nouveau cap en vue
place à notre dream
décryptage avec nos invités et pour en
parler nous sommes avec un jour paul est
mon médecin généraliste président
d'honneur de la fédération des médecins
de france bonsoir jean paul agir si
d'être avec nous kamel boulhadid chef
d'entreprise à la tête de plusieurs
franchises qui aimait la maladie qui est
en liaison avec nous par téléphone en a
eu un petit souci de steaks juste avant
cette émission et puis alexis poulain
éditorialistes bonsoir alexis et merci
d'être avec nous en direct également sur
rt france emmanuel macron qui va
s'adresser aux français une nouvelle
fois demain poursuite du confinement ou
début du déconfinement ne sais pas trop
quoi dire qu'attendez-vous de cette
prise de parole quel message docteur
jean paul hamon moi je pense que nous
médecins on n'attend pas grand-chose on
attend surtout je pense que ceux qui
attendent ce sont les petits commerçants
ce qui
on fait beaucoup d'efforts pour
justement que le virus ne se transmet
pas qu'ils ont du gel dans leurs
boutiques qui ont qui impose le masque
qui prennent très peu de clients à la
fois
donc ces gens là attendent certainement
avec impatience que les commerces
puissent ouvrir puisque les fêtes de
noël approchent et et ils ont déjà eu
ils ont déjà eu à subir un premier
confinement est pour eux ça doit être
très dur
on aimerait bien aussi que le président
annonce que qu'ils permettent aux jeunes
aux jeunes scolaires aux adolescents et
aux enfants de de pouvoir reprendre les
compétitions sportives en plein air j'ai
vu que les championnats de judo s'était
déroulé je suis toujours un peu surprise
de devoir que le judo puisse se dérouler
c'est heureux pour les judokas mais je
trouve que quand même là les distances
sont pas respectées les gens nos points
de base qui sont proches les uns des
autres
il y en a qui font des des
immobilisations à terre et je suis un
petit peu surpris que cette compétition
puisse avoir lieu
alors que des enfants qui pourrait jouer
au foot en plein air ne peuvent pas le
faire donc tout ça c'est c'est un petit
peu dommage mais je pense sincèrement
qu'il faut tout simplement rappeler aux
français que malheureusement il faut
qu'on s'installe dans la durée et que si
on veut s'installer dans la durée et
éviter que cette épidémie ne se
développe il faut tout simplement
rappelé les mesures barrières le masque
la distance le lavage des mains et
malgré l'hiver qui s'approche
l'aération des pièces car ne pas oublier
que à l'intérieur des familles la
contamination se fait tout autant qu'aux
écoles tout étant que dans les lieux de
travail
merci jean paul eymond et vous m
emmanuel macron qui s'exprime et
justement dans le journal du dimanche
qui avoue par les docteurs il ya
quelques instants de la cohérence
écouter ce qu'on les hait président de
la république
rien n'est pire que l'incertitude et
l'impression d'une morosité sans fin il
faut de la cohérence de la clarté un cap
savoir ensemble nous allons et comment y
aller
alexis poulain jean paul hamon nous le
signaler il n'y avait pas de toujours de
la cohérence alors
ce deuxième confinement ni au premier
d'ailleurs il était temps de s'en rendre
compte la cohérence la clarté enfin je
ne sais pas si demain on aura droit à la
cohérence et la clarté on ne l'a jamais
eu 1 depuis le mois de mars on a eu
l'impression
on a eu des mesures ubuesque à tel point
que la presse étrangère parler en
parlant de la france d' absurde distant
totalitaire et on à emmanuel macron qui
parlent de nous allons réussir ensemble
et qui décide seul
il s'est enfermé tout le week end à
l'elysée pour préparer cette allocution
de demain selon le jdd et puis ce
conseil de défense qui a petit à petit
remplacer le conseil des ministres
conseil de défense placées sous le sceau
du secret défense donc aucune
transparence pour savoir comment sont
pris ces décisions qui impliquent des
millions de français millions de
français qui se demande finalement
pourquoi cette crise à gérer de cette
façon là pourquoi cette crise sanitaire
est en train de devenir une crise
économique majeure
parce que confiné des confiné ne pas
donner effectivement d'horizon clair
pour les entreprises les aides qui ne
seront pas à la hauteur parce qu'elles
sont donnés sans distinction entre les
entreprises qui vont bien et celles qui
ne vont pas bien
on apprend que danone par exemple à
distribuer des dividendes a récupéré des
aides et va pourtant mettre plus de 1000
personnes sur le carreau les plans
sociaux vont se multiplier et ses
annonces
eh bien elles sont là uniquement pour
temporiser sans doute pour dire aux
français ne vous inquiétez pas vous
allez pouvoir passer noël en faisant
attention
et puis on verra en janvier et en
janvier que se passera-t-il sans doute
1re confinement on peut se poser la
question des chiffres aussi qui s'affole
un ces derniers jours on se pose la
question
de savoir si est ce que le confinement a
été utile ou non est ce que le
couvre-feu est il utile ou non puisque
les courbes se seraient déjà inversée
avant cela il ya beaucoup de questions
en réalité sur la gestion de cette crise
sanitaire et puis il ya beaucoup de
questions sur ce virus le cnrs qui
continuent de se demander l'origine du
virus aujourd'hui toutes les hypothèses
sont sur la table
et pourtant ça mouline dans les big
pharmas les vaccins sont quasiment prêt
prêt à être mis sur le marché mais on ne
sait toujours pas d'où vient ce virus
alors c'est quand même étrange de voir
que nous sommes pendu finalement à
l'allocution d'un chef d'état qui décide
par décret de vente ou non de sapins de
noël et qui demain je ne sais pas ce
qu'il va annoncer mais pour la clarté
il repassera kamel boulhadid vous êtes
un pendu justement suspendus aux lèvres
de chef de l'état demain comme le dit
alexis poulain quel est votre état
d'esprit ce soir qu'est ce que vous
attendez mon état d'esprit je vais
revenir quand même sur quelque chose qui
est extrêmement important et qui remonte
du mois de mars
et on entend encore notre premier
ministre fin octobre qui nous dit que il
est irresponsable de laisser les
commerces ouverts et les entreprises
que ce soit dans la restauration que ce
soit dans l'hôtellerie qui s'assoit dans
les événements événementiel que ce soit
nos théâtres nos librairies nos petits
commerces
alors qui est vraiment irresponsable
d'avoir fermé des dizaines d'hôpitaux en
france qui est vraiment irresponsable
d'avoir laissé une situation dramatique
pour tous nos médecins nos infirmières
nous aide soignant avec des salaires aux
dbacks même en formation n'en ai plus
envie de venir travailler à l'hôpital
qui est vraiment responsable aujourd'hui
de la faillite programmée de centaines
de milliers d'entreprises en france que
ce soit des commerces que ce soit des
artisans que ce soit des
auto-entrepreneurs dans tous les
domaines exactement
d'accord qui est vraiment est
responsable aujourd'hui de la perte
d'emploi de millions de personnes en
france
moi c'est la question que je me pose
quand le premier ministre ont dit c'est
irresponsable
mais toutes les rides irresponsabilité
aujourd'hui repose sur le dos de nous de
nous de deux chefs d'entreprise de
commerçants d'artisans d'employer des
gens aujourd'hui qu'ils ont fini leurs
études et qui ne savent et qui ne
peuvent pas trouver un travail qui est
responsable de cette situation
moi je leur pose la question qui est
irresponsable aujourd'hui d'aller dans
les grandes surfaces et de voir des
centaines de personnes touchées des
légumes des paquets de gâteaux et
aujourd'hui on interdit à nos
commerçants madame de faire du des
affaires et de leur autoriser huit
mètres carrés par client comment
pouvez-vous vivre en baissant votre
chiffre d'affaires de 100 % pendant ces
six derniers mois
est-ce que vous en étant journaliste est
ce que vous pouvez vivre sans salaire
pendant six mois d'un mettez vous à la
place de ces centaines de milliers de
commerçants qui ont investi dans leurs
affaires et qui aujourd'hui n'ont plus
rien nous n'aurons plus rien demain
parce que ce que nous disent nos
gouvernants concernant les aides de
kells est dit par madame il parle d'une
dette sur de la dette
c'est exactement ça de quoi il parle
qu'il va payer les congés payés de nos
salariés fait deux jours et demi par
mois par salarié madame quand vous avez
pas ado la haye euros qui rentrent dans
vos quêtes
comment vous faites pour payer les
congés payés de vos salariés
comment vous faites pour payer votre
dette bancaire
vos frais financiers vos loyers qui
représentent aujourd'hui dans nos
infrastructures d'entreprise entre 20 et
25 % de frais généraux
dites moi comment qui peut-être limoges
kamel boulhadid je ne suis pas c'est pas
encore partie du gouvernement donc voilà
je ne peux que relayer ce soir voir
votre parole avec grand plaisir
d'ailleurs on va y revenir justement
parce que 85% des français craignent une
explosion sociale précisément dans les
prochains mois la situation économique
de plusieurs secteurs et dramatique on
vient d'entendre votre cri du coeur les
commerçants qui s'impatientent leur
réouverture est vital comme a pu le
constater justement ce matin à notre
reporter à paris nenê jallet razak et on
revient sur nos invités nous sommes
boulevard haussmann devant les célèbres
galeries lafayette en temps normal est
d'autant
cette époque de l'année les lieux sont
bondés mais depuis la mise en place du
deuxième confinement pour lutter contre
le coronel virus l'endroit est quasi
désertique
nous allons perdre la moitié de notre
chiffre d'affaires sur l'ensemble de
l'année ce qui va entraîner des pertes
d'exploitation très significatives comme
nous n'en avions jamais enregistré
depuis 25 ans nous évaluons les pertes à
1,7 milliard d'euros lé commerce non
essentiels ont donc été obligés de
baisser les rideaux
impossible de se rendre dans une
librairie c'est dans un restaurant dans
un magasin de vêtements ou encore chez
le coiffeur
le manque à gagner pour ces commerces
devraient atteindre 4 milliards 400
millions d'euros selon l'assureur crédit
euler hermes
et si la mesure de fermeture devait se
prolonger au cours du mois de décembre
les pertes pourraient s'établir à 10
milliards 800 millions d'euros
les quelques assouplissements accordées
par l'état click and collect livraison à
domicile et l'adoption rapide des outils
digitaux par les commerçants ont permis
de limiter quelque peu ce manque à
gagner
nous estimons qu'une fermeture complète
des commerces non essentiels physique en
novembre et décembre est donc une
absence totale de vente aurait engendré
un manque à gagner de 18 milliards
d'euros pour les entreprises concernées
déjà fragilisé par le premier
confinement et ses commerces naissance
qu'elles ont subi un manque à gagner et
qui n'a pas été compensée par le rebond
de la demande
enregistré entre juin et septembre
dernier quand on est chef d'entreprise
on n'a plus peur de la faillite que duke
au vide pour l'instant on a gelé les
dettes
on a décalé les remboursements de
charger d'emprunt certains loyers ne
sont pas payés mais un moment tout va
s'arrêter
certaines banques n'acceptent déjà plus
de décaler les remboursements d'emprunts
on va se retrouver face à des
entreprises qui seront en défaut de
paiement
chômage partiel reports et annulations
de charges et d'impôts
une fois que les dispositifs d'aidé
d'urgence de l'état arriveront à
échéance
de nombreuses entreprises craignent de
ne pas pouvoir se relever
d'ailleurs selon l'observatoire français
des conjonctures économiques
près de cent mille sociétés devraient
disparaître d'ici la fin de l'année
entraînant dans leur sillage la
suppression de 250 mille emplois
si les indicateurs sanitaires le
permettent emmanuel macron pourrait dans
son allocution de mardi soir annoncé la
réouverture des commerces neuner
essentielle pour samedi prochain et pour
rattraper le temps et l'argent perdu ils
pourraient être autorisés à ouvrir tous
les dimanches de décembre
pas sûr pour autant que cette mesure
suffise à limiter la casse avant
d'ordonner la parole un autre chef
d'entreprise justement principalement
concernés à quai mais la maladie je
voulais faire réagir le docteur amont
les chefs d'entreprise qui ont plus peur
de la faillite que duke au vide docteur
ça vous évoque quoi cette remarque parce
qu'on a souvent opposé on le fait encore
santé contre économie finalement ça
paraît compliqué de sortir de ce schéma
là aujourd'hui ça paraît effectivement
compliqué moi je serais pas aussi sévère
que vos deux interlocuteurs avec le avec
le gouvernement c'est vrai que j'ai pas
j'ai pas été tendre avec ce gouvernement
mais quand on voit ce qui se passe dans
les autres pays européens
y compris dans la grande russie on voit
bien que les gens sont sont confrontés à
une épidémie qu'on contrôle très mal et
donc le système tout à toute l'europe
est touché tout le monde est touché et
on voit bien que legault les
gouvernements quels qu'ils soient ont
les plus grandes difficultés à faire
leur équilibre entre la pandémie et
l'économie on sait bien on voit bien que
il fallait le le confinement le
couvre-feu a fait de l'effet et on voit
bien que là on recommence à avoir
quelque chose qui est qui est
supportable même si on est encore loin
des 5000 cas quotidiens qui ferait que
le système pourrait être complètement à
l' équilibre
c'est vrai que c'est vrai que c'est pas
facile de gouverner en ce moment mais
honnêtement ils ont fait comme il
fallait
même si même si on peut effectivement
s'énerver que ce soit à des médecins des
ip du biologiste qui prennent des
décisions qui qui reflète sur sur la vie
économique mais mais en même temps quand
on avait entendu monsieur delfraissy le
professeur delfraissy dire que le
gouvernement devait prendre des mesures
drastiques et qu'elle n'avait pas été
prise parce que le gouvernement essayait
de maintenir l'économie
on a bien vu que ça n'a pas empêché de
l'épidémie de redémarrer le premier
confinement avaient porté ses fruits
l'été l'été a permis de vérifier que le
virus circule est toujours s'il ya eu
une erreur de fait c'est dans l'absence
du nombre de tests au mois de septembre
qui nous aurait permis de contenir un
peu plus de tester et de tracer et
d'isoler rapidement les patients sera
peut-être été moins important si on
avait pu tester autant de personnes mais
surtout à avoir des résultats beaucoup
plus rapidement pour isoler les
personnes mais sincèrement
quel que soit le gouvernement d'où qu'il
soit quel que soit le pays
pour le moment il n'y a aucun aucun pays
qui s'en sort mieux que les autres la
suède qui s'en sortait mieux jusqu'ici
vient de recommencer à prendre des
mesures
sur beaucoup plus drastiques qu'il
n'avait donc sincèrement je ne tape pas
utile moi je taperai pas sur la sur la
politique et et franchement dire que le
président décide tout seul ça m'épate un
peu parce que je sais que qui se fait
conseiller à droite et à gauche et
plutôt deux fois qu'une kamel boulhadid
on l'appelle vous avez environ 60
franchise dans le grand test des marques
prestigieuses on va pas les citer ici
aujourd'hui vous êtes tous même
indulgent quand même avec le
gouvernement on n'aurait pas pu faire
mieux qu est ce que vous lui demandez
concrètement on imagine que c'est très
compliqué pour vous aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui concrètement on a eu 2 dead
la première que toute la france a
bénéficié en tout cas tous les chefs
d'entreprise c'est le chômage partiel
concrètement heureusement que le
gouvernement a mis cette mesure en place
parce que je pense qu'en france il y
aurait 12 millions de chômeurs
concrètement donc c'est la protection
pour nos salariés et c'est bien que ça a
été fait à ce niveau là là j'ai aucun
souci avec ça et heureusement qu'ils ont
mis en place rapidement et qu'ils ont
mis ce degré de rénumération à 84%
je vais dire sans pourtant nickel y'a
pas de soucis le deuxième sur ce qu'ils
ont mis en place effectivement pour
aider des entreprises c'est le pge
mais le pedn a lancé une dette sur de la
dette d'accor série dette à devenir qui
bat une tombée dessus dans les l'année
prochaine dans les deux trois quatre
années qui vont suivre et qu'on devra de
toute manière payés avec des intérêts et
le capital bien sûr restant dû d'accord
donc ça fait encore une fois une aide
qui va qu'abc devoir supporter bon
nombre de sociétés
il ya plein de société malheureusement
aujourd'hui qu'ils ne pourront pas
supporter cette dette sur glane est
d'accord la troisième chose qu'on ne
fera pas supporté effectivement c'est
tout ce qui concerne nos frais généraux
faut savoir que dans les frais généraux
même sont à des reports de loyer même si
on a des reports de charges un moment
donné faudra passer à la caisse et
faudra payer
et là le problème c'est que ça fait six
mois qu'on est en activité sans activité
imaginez vous
l'accumulation de dettes que nous avons
de petites dettes qui viennent
s'accumuler comme dans un petit sac avec
et vous rajoutez à chaque fois une
pierre une pierre en pierre pour payer
cette dette à la sortie il faudra faire
entre 120 et 130 % de notre chiffre
d'affaires qu'on faisait avant postaux
vise avant la crise
d'accord si on n'a pas réussi à le faire
avant qui nous dit aujourd'hui qu'on va
pouvoir réussir à le faire et c'est là
où votre portage a été très bien fait et
là les personnes qui ont parlé où il y
aura une crise majeure de toutes ces
petites sociétés qui n'ont pas les fonds
propres pour pouvoir tenir un tel et tel
vague de de dettes qui vont devoir
malheureusement déposé le bilan et la
revalorisation de leurs affaires leurs
balles la valorisation pour ces braves
gens qui travaillent depuis des années
pour construire leurs retraites de
demain elle bat tombé à l'eau au madame
il n'y aura plus rien pour eux alors je
suis tout à fait d'accord avec le
docteur sur le fait que cette piste en
terre sans précédent fait qu'il ya de
nombreuses personnes malheureusement qui
subissent cette cette pandémie mais nous
même ne sommes pas responsables à 100%
de tout ça c'est des infrastructures du
gouvernement les actes et décisions
gouvernement qui ont fait qu'aujourd'hui
nos médecins aux hôpitaux noah dernières
ne peuvent pas suivre le ce rythme là
mais si on était suffisamment organisés
on aurait pu réduire au maximum 7 cette
cause importante qu'on va tous subir et
les aides ne concerne pas non plus
malins les congés payés de nos salariés
qui représentent 2,5 jours par mois
travaillé et aujourd'hui une société qui
a dix salariés qui permet depuis six
mois
elle accumule autant de congés payés
comment fait-elle pour payer cette dette
qu'elle doit ses salariés ciel boulaïd
nous nous parle à nouveau de la
responsable
du gouvernement jean castex hier dans
les colonnes du jdd et rohff voilà s'est
confié on a déconné collectivement c'est
un début tout de même de mea culpa de la
part du premier ministre
c'est un mea culpa mais il faut qu'ils
soient suivies d'actes forts pour nos
sociétés pour que nos entreprises
quel intérêt à agir aussi parce que vous
êtes 3 effectivement alexis poulain ben
c'est quand même moi j'ai l'impression
que ce gouvernement c'est un peu un
médecin du moyen-âge qui fait une
saignée pour le malade et qui est en
train de tuer le malade il faut savoir
que 90 pour cent de l'emploi c'est les
pme et les petites les tpe les très
petites entreprises les pme qui vont
être saignée par cette ce choix d'avoir
enfermé tout le monde pendant des mois
parce qu'il n'y avait plus rien d'autre
à faire c'était la dernière solution
parce que on a menti sur les masques
parce qu'ensuite on n'a pas voulu
essayer certains traitements karine
lacombe dit il faut faire avec leur md
et dire vous allez voir ça va être super
leur md est dir est interdit maintenant
par le la santé mondiale en disant que
c'est un médicament dangereux
finalement ce médicament et qu'il ne
sert à rien alors faire confiance je ne
sais pas par qui se fait conseiller mais
le maquereau c'est bien tout le problème
qui conseille dans le conseil de défense
et me les maquereaux et en dehors du
conseil de défense pour que des choix
aussi catastrophique soient faits les
uns après les autres les mensonges sur
les masques la fiasco des tests la
rentrée non organisée par jean michel
blanquer repris encore dans une
tourmente en ce moment sur un
syndicaliste hermé reparlons de la façon
dont ce ministre n'a pas organisé la
rentrée en septembre
et aujourd'hui on fait payer la note aux
petits commerces au restaurant au bar
mais aussi à la culture tous les lieux
qui font le lien qui font que les
français les humains peuvent se
rassembler se retrouver sont fermés et
on est en train de tuer un pays si non
seulement son économie mais ce qui fait
qu'on peut vivre ensemble alors on peut
dire que c'est la faute au virus que
c'est la faute aux français qui n'ont
pas été qui n'ont pas obéi aux consignes
qui ont fait n'importe quoi pendant
l'été on leur a dit de faire ce qu'il
voulait c'était très bien l'été c'était
comme si on avait gagné cette guerre
contre le virus
pas du tout il était toujours là sauf
qu'ils n'attendaient que la rentrée pour
revenir on n'a pas planifié le
gouvernement à continuer de fermer des
lits
pendant l'été est plutôt que de prévenir
alors je ne dis pas quévy évidemment il
faut faire mieux formés et des soignants
et avoir délit et que même si on en
avait suffisamment
l'idée c'est que il faut éviter que les
gens attrapent ce virus bien entendu
mais le confinement c'est la dernière la
toute dernière des solutions est arrivé
à fermer les commerces de la façon dont
on l'a fait monsieur l'a très bien
rappelé les entreprises aujourd'hui si
elles sont aidées
elles ne seront pas aidés quand il va
falloir rembourser la dette quand il va
falloir arriver devant le banquier et
les banquiers vont les lâcher parce que
derrière la faillite les petites
entreprises c'est la faillite systémique
des banques qui est qui est en jeu et
les milliards du plan de relance
européen n'y changeront rien parce que
l'activité économique ne va pas
redémarré et ses millions d'emplois que
nous allons perdre parce que les
entreprises les petites entreprises vont
fermer la porte
on va pas les retrouver parce que
l'activité économique ne sera pas à la
hauteur
et là je crois que le gouvernement n'a
pas plan du tout à part peut-être de
faire des lois maintenant on en parle la
loi de sécurité globale pour préparer
une répression parce qu'il y aurait trop
de monde dans la rue mais eux évidemment
80% des français s'attendent à un
mouvement social massif c'est l'évidence
même
et malheureusement le gouvernement ne
fait rien pour contrecarrer et bien ce
qui est déjà écrit malheureuse merci en
tout cas tous les trois d'avoir apporté
votre opinion et vos analyses
il en direct sur un rt france merci à
vous et on va évoquer ces chiffres ces
derniers chiffres du coronavirus en
france santé publique dénombre 4452
carte de kobe détecté en 24 heures un
chiffre en forte baisse par rapport à
lundi dernier cinq cent une personnes
qui sont décédées à l'hôpital ces
dernières 24 heures le taux de
positivité des tests s'établit désormais
à 13 3% et poursuit sa baisse et puis à
noter dans l'actualité également qu'une
opération a eu lieu il y à peu place de
la république à paris l'installation
d'un camp migrants les images sont
fortes regard des détenteurs ont été
déployés sur la place plusieurs
associations sont présents dont utopia
56 qui vient en aide aux migrants qui a
organisé l'opération cette installation
fait suite à l'évacuation du camp saint
denis il y a six jours à la suite de
laquelle plusieurs centaines de
personnes n'ont toujours pas trouvé de
solution d'hébergement et forces de
l'ordre sont intervenues il y à quelques
minutes et démantèle en ce moment se
prend à peine monté plus d'informations
évidemment dans nos prochaines éditions
restez avec nous dans quelques instants
direction les états unis alors que joe
biden vient de présenter son futur
gouvernement donald trump lui n'a
toujours pas reconnu sa défaite et
continue ses recours devant la justice
qui nous évoquerons le retrait américain
du traité ciel ouvert qui permet de
vérifier les mouvements militaires et
les mesures de limitation des armements
des pays signataires
[Musique]
à l'époque il y avait une concurrence
qui était assez violente d'ailleurs
entre les russes et les américains alors
que j'étais destinée à voler avec les
russes oui une opportunité s'est ouverte
de faire partie du deuxième groupe
d'astronautes européens qui m'a envoyé
aussitôt à la nasa
et là j'ai une chance extraordinaire de
la nasa m'a entraîné qualifié affecté en
vol comme un des leurs on est loin de la
guerre des étoiles à en est quand même
dans une espèce de con fraternité et de
solidarité l'exploration au sens large
est une activité en coopération
internationale où on se rend service
entre nations qui pourtant au même
moment son sujet d'embargo et de
conflits géopolitiques savoir est ce que
l'homme peut vivre et travailler dans
l'espace est ce qu'il existe de la vie
ailleurs
est ce qu'on pourra un jour s'installer
durablement sur d'autres corps célestes
tout sans le fait en coopération
internationale
malgré des tensions
à la surface de l'eau calme
[Musique]
20h30 soyez les bienvenus
heure française en direct sur arte
france aux états unis joe biden commence
à lever le voile sur son futur
gouvernement
le président élu qui poursuit pour le
moment une transition unilatérale à deux
mois de son investiture
anthony blinken francophones et
francophiles est nommé à la tête de la
diplomatie il succédera ainsi à mâcon p
o
john kerry le voilà lui et représentant
spécial pour le climat et pour la
première fois un hispanique alejandro
mayorkas ce qui est nommé à la sécurité
intérieure j'ai besoin d'une équipe
prête au premier jour précise joe biden
quant à donald trump lui il n'est
toujours pas déterminée a abandonné 30
trois recours ont été déposés devant la
justice 31 abandonnés ou rejeter les
chiffres qui n'enlève rien en soutien
des partisans du président sortant au
moment où joe biden annonce la formation
donc de son gouvernement
david khalifa un soutien infaillible
pour un président qui n'acceptent
toujours pas sa défaite la vindicte
populaire et aux côtés de donald trump
déterminé à se battre jusqu'au bout
un soulèvement républicain qui effraie
le possible futur locataire de la maison
blanche
laissez-moi choisir mes mots je pense
qu'ils sont témoins d'une incroyable
irresponsabilité de messages
incroyablement dangereux envoyé au reste
du monde sur le fonctionnement de la
démocratie
près de 80 millions d'électeurs
américains ont choisi le candidat
démocrate
malgré ça donald trump multiplie les
recours en justice pour contester sans
fondement les résultats de l'élection
sur les 33 plaintes déposées par le
président sortant
trump et ses alliés ont subi des échecs
à trente et une reprise parmi elles la
plainte déposée concernant le vote par
correspondance en pennsylvanie un juge
fédéral de l'état a catégoriquement
rejeté les arguments
edit sans fondement et les accusations
hypothétique de fraude électorale du
président sortant
aux etats unis d'amérique cela ne peut
justifier la privation du droit de vote
d'un seul électeur et encore moins de
tous les électeurs du sixième état le
plus peuplé du pays notre peuple nos
lois et nos institutions exige plus que
cela une déclaration loin de démotiver
l'équipe d'avocats de donald trump
dirigée par l'ancien maire de new york
rudolf giuliani
l'objectif pour eux étant d'aller devant
la cour suprême
pourquoi joe biden forme-t-il si
rapidement un cabinet alors que mes
enquêteurs ont trouvé des centaines de
milliers de votes frauduleux
assez pour retourner au moins quatre
états ce qui à son tour est plus que
suffisant pour remporter les élections
espérons que les tribunaux et où les
législatures auront le courage de faire
ce qui doit être fait pour maintenir
l'intégrité nos élections et les états
unis d'amérique eux mêmes le monde
regarde la pennsylvanie est une pièce
essentielle de la stratégie mise en
place par donald trump pour tenter
d'annuler le vote est de se maintenir
pour un second mandat à la maison
blanche
mais ce recours s'effondrent comme dans
d'autres états clés telles que la
géorgie l'arizona et le michigan
les responsables chargés des élections à
travers le pays ont dit n'avoir aucune
preuve d'une fraude électorale
significative mais rien n'y fait donald
trump poursuivra sa bataille juridique
et politique jusqu'au bout pour empêcher
une transition qui semble pourtant
inévitable et pour en parler nous sommes
en direct depuis new york avec
jean-claude gruffat homme d'affaires
franco américain c'est notre rubrique vu
de l'extérieur ce soit
[Musique]
bonsoir jean claude de femmes merci
d'être avec nous en direct sur rt france
joe biden qui commence donc à dévoiler
son futur gouvernement alors que tron
continue ses recours pour contester sa
défaite
anthony blinken à la diplomatie john
terry pour le climat pour la première
fois un hispanique alejandro mayorkas ça
la sécurité intérieure que vous
inspirent ces premiers noms dévoilés
bonsoir tout simplement trop bas et des
choix dit des gens qu'il connaît qui ont
travaillé avec lui leur ses fonctions
antérieures ou qu'ils sont toujours
j'allais dire d'un cercle rapproché des
personnes qu'il connaît et dans
lesquelles il ya eu l'entière confiance
sans porter attention à leur orientation
idéologique à l'intérieur deux parties
puisque il y a comme vous savez la
période parti démocrate qui avait édité
pour ne pas la saisir
3 qu'il y avait aussi une grande
diversité sur les choix politiques et
que les digues fiscaux financiers
or là on voit pas eden choisir ce que
j'appellerais chez garde rapprochée pour
l'instant aucune conclusion qu'un dessin
sur ce que pourrait être par exemple la
politique étrangère puisque anthony
blinken
la tête de la diplomatie on peut en
tirer certaines réflexions
non je crois qu'il n'y aura pas de
changements fondamentaux dans la vie et
de la politique projet quelques est
historiquement a fait du parti là qu'on
peut attendre c'est qu'effectivement des
changements de style peut-être des
gaillards qui sont un peu moins proche
peut-être que les relations avec les
femmes d'arabie saoudite sont un peu
plus qui se tendent qu'elle ne l'était
du temps 2-3 et je ne crois pas qu'il y
ait encore roi avec la rue oui
effectivement puisque joe biden avait
annoncé que la russie était certainement
pour le biais d'un des piles et les plus
menaçant lors d'une interview à une
chaîne américaine
fin de la parenthèse alors sur les
trente trois recours déposés par
l'équipe de donald trump 22 ont déjà été
retoqué ce week-end en pennsylvanie un
juge fédéral a rejeté les accusations de
fraude
c'est un coup dur pour l'équipe trump
l'étau se resserre ça va être amputé d'
inverser la tendance
je crois que vous avez je crois qu'il
faut se voir les choses avec un certain
recul
ce qui est en train de se passer c'est
qu'il ya eu effectivement un certain
nombre de recours et que ces recours
portent sur des chiffres qui ne
permettent pas d'inverser les résultats
est à peu près 5 6 et a dit anton
bascule ce qu'on appelle ici les criques
state qui effectivement ont donné la
victoire finale à enerpart servant de
siège au kilo du collège électoral il
aura un peu plus de 300 ans ou 260 aucun
des états l'a montré même avec des
ajustements des voix parce qu'il ya eu
essaieront des secondes ça existe huit
ans on parle de quelques dizaines ou
quelques centaines des voix or dans les
faits et à baden a gardé a gagné par des
majorités délai de dix villes 15000 donc
rien ainsi qu' heureusement su refaire
il n'entraîneront pas de bascule d'état
et donc le 14 200 quand les délégués au
collège électoral vent sont réunis à
l'enjeu eh bien ils confirmeront que
baye est effectivement le président elec
donc je crois que keith à seulement 6
juillet des combats d'arrière-garde
d'ailleurs c'est l'opinion de tous
enfuis général même chez pika rubik qui
traque les pas de remettre en cause les
résultats de l'élection et de constituer
un courant est fort ce soit pour se
protéger d'éventuels trotter poursuites
judiciaires ou de deux problèmes le
il y là un futur c'est quand même un peu
compliqué il ya un certain nombre
d'affaires qui a été mise en suspens
parce que il était le président alors
qu'il avait utilisé deux fonctions mais
il a des affaires personnelles
agressions et autres et de libérer tous
et non pas en tout cas elles n'ont pas
été jugés la descente et fiscales
il a aussi des problèmes avec certaines
de ces banques ont tout ça ce sont des
problèmes qui l'attendent
et donc il est de bonne guerre si
j'utilise d'essayer de trouver un ou
deux thèmes qui permettent de paon
aborder ces questions de sato je crois
que lui laissant en poissons présentés
en 2024
ces lois 2024 donc ce qui est
intéressant de noter d'ailleurs en
référé partiel
cette sélection c'est que tout le monde
parle de la victoire de bayonne qui
n'est pas contesté elle n'est pas
véritablement contester sérieusement
contesté en revanche ce que l'on pense
que si byden a été élu c'est surtout
parce qu'il était mon titre mais en
revanche les démocrates n'ont pas fait
de bons arrêts mais ils ont perdu
déboires en chambre et au sénat
ils n'ont pas la majorité qui pourrait
la voir
ils nous ont fait les deux sièges qui
sont en réflexion au début du mois de
janvier
et c'est là d'ailleurs retrouve la
stratégie dans ce rapport aux
républicains qui veulent pas laisser
tomber trois trop tôt parce qu'il a
besoin de son soutien pour faire élire
ses deux sénateurs en chirurgie qui sont
essentiels pour la majorité est du kenya
merci en tout cas jean tordeur gruffat
homme d'affaires franco américain
d'avoir été avec nous pour vu de
l'extérieur ce soir et si de nombreuses
capitales ont déjà salué la victoire de
joe biden moscou attend toujours la
confirmation des grands électeurs le 14
décembre et la validation des résultats
par l'administration des services
généraux
la correspondance en russie d'antoine
claireaux la position du président russe
reste inchangée depuis les premiers
résultats annoncés par les médias
américains
des résultats de notre job idle
vainqueur de cette élection à savoir pas
de reconnaissance de cette victoire sans
proclamations officielles et surtout
tant que les recours de donald trump ne
trouve une issue
premièrement un président élu doit être
proclamé le président sortant doit
reconnaître les résultats des élections
et tous les procès juridique doivent
être achevés ce n'est qu'après cela que
le bilan des élections sera
officiellement proclamée de toute
évidence cela ne s'est pas encore
produit autrement dit vladimir poutine
ne s'exprimera sur le sujet seulement
lorsque seront épuisés tous les procès
et autres recours juridiques intentées
par le candidat républicain
ils doivent tous être terminée sans cela
les élections ne seront pas
officiellement achevé
c'est précisément ce que le président a
déjà dit à plusieurs reprises et au
regard des difficultés rencontrées par
donald trump dans ses différentes
démarches judiciaires
c'est bien joe biden qui devraient être
proclamés 46e président des états unis
n'en déplaise à moscou qui s'attend à
des relations houleuses avec le nouveau
locataire de la maison blanche
quoi qu'il en soit de l'aveu même de
vladimir poutine ce sera difficile de
détériorer davantage des relations russo
américaines
déjà au plus bas et simon après les
annonces faites par l'administration de
donald trump c'est officiel depuis hier
les états unis ont quitté le traité
international ciel ouvert les détails en
images avec les locaux il l'avait promis
le 22 mai dernier six mois plus tard cet
effectif les états unis ont quitté
l'accord international ciel ouvert à
l'époque tonale train de pointer du
doigt la russie pour le président
américain
moscou n'applique pas les termes du
traité la russie n'a pas respecté le
traité
tant qu'il ne le respecteront pas nous
nous retirons il y eu une très bonne
chance que nous puissions passer un
nouvel accord ou faire quelque chose
afin de rétablir cet accord mais quand
il y à un accord que l'une des parties
ne respecte pas vous savez nous avons
beaucoup d'accords comme ça dans le
monde
quand il ya un accord entre deux parties
et qui n'y adhèrent pas et que nous nous
y adhérons quand nous avons des choses
comme ça il nous retirons aussi c'est
pourquoi avec les traités sur les armes
si vous regardez les traités sur les
armes nous allons probablement conclure
un accord avec la russie et la chine
sera peut être incluse nous allons voir
ce qui se passe parmi les violations
dénoncées par washington une
interdiction faite aux avions des pays
membres du traité de s'approcher de plus
de 500 kilomètres de l'enclavé russe de
kaliningrad et de dépasser de 10 km la
frontière entre la russie et la géorgie
des accusations immédiatement démentie
par moscou il n'y a aucune violation de
la part de la russie
toutes ces questions soulevées par les
états unis font l'objet de discussions
dans le cadre de la commission
consultative sur le traité ciel ouvert
d'ailleurs nous avons des réclamations
sérieuse quant à l exécution des
dispositions du traité de la part des
états unis eux mêmes
nous déplorons le retrait des états unis
de l'accord nous estimons que ce traité
constitue un élément très important dans
le renforcement de la confiance mutuelle
en général ainsi que dans la maîtrise
des armements si vous vous souvenez
dès le début quand les etats unis ont
annoncé leur intention de se retirer de
ce traité nous avons dit que cette
décision aurait des conséquences
négatives et qu'après le retrait des
états unis le traité en l'huile elle ne
serait plus viable
dès cette annonce en mai dernier dix
pays de l'ue ont dit regretter la
décision américaine de sortir de cet
accord signé à helsinki le 24 mars 1992
est entrée en vigueur en 2002 le traité
ciel ouvert vise à vérifier les
mouvements de troupes et les mesures de
limitation des armements de 35 pays
signataires les états parties s'engagent
à soumettre leur territoire à des
survols aériens pacifique par les autres
états membres
mais le retrait américain ne pourrait
être que de courte durée
d'après un diplomate russe
l'administration de joe biden pourrait
envisager de réintégrer le traité après
sa prise de fonctions en janvier
prochain et pour en parler nous sommes
avec claude blanchemaison expert en
relations internationales bonsoir claude
georges maison merci d'être avec nous on
revient un petit peu dans le passé
pourquoi les etats-unis se tire-t-il de
ce traité ciel ouvert ben comme vous
l'avez dit dans votre sujet au bois de
mais donald trump a accusé la russie de
ne pas respecter l'esprit du traité est
en entière des gens le survol de
certaines zones
en effet à kaliningrad et aussi près de
la frontière de la quasi et de l'ossétie
du sud mais en fait cette sortie six
mois plus tard c'est ce qui était prévu
dans deux dans le traité montre bien que
donald trump a une certaine allergie à
tout dispositif plus qui latéral il
considère qu'il est plus commode de
jouer le rapport de force bilatérale
pour favoriser les intérêts des états
unis
et puis c'est l'un des épisodes nombreux
du retrait des états unis des traités
signés notamment avec la russie
parfois avec l'union soviétique qui
étaient des traités de contrôle des
armements donc des traités de
désarmement est en effet les états unis
ne supporte pas d'être contraint avec un
budget
et militaires qui est 12 soit celui de
la russie ils considèrent qu'ils ont
plutôt intérêt à ne pas être liés par
des traités de ce genre et puis enfin
dernier élément tous les pays les états
unis la russie mais aussi la france et
beaucoup d'autres possèdent des des
satellites militaires qui ont un degré
de précision qui permet de saisir au sol
des deux des éléments très très très
petit inférieur à 1 mètre et par
conséquent finalement est-ce que ce
traité sur le ciel ouvert n'a pas
finalement une valeur est
essentiellement symbolique
ce traité est il toujours adaptés au
monde qui nous entoure
oui alors évidemment on a bien vu que la
russie mais aussi la pente l'allemagne
et la plupart des pays signataires
regrettent le départ des etats-unis et
considère que le traité doit continuer
de s'appliquer
et en plus on prévoir un probable retour
de jobs hayden lorsqu'il sera à la
maison blanche
donc si tous ces pays s'intéressent à ce
traité c'est qu'il y attachent un prix
ça veut donc dire qu'il a un sens mais
il s'est un traité encore une fois qui a
été conçu à l'époque de la guerre froide
même s'il n'a été signé qu'après la fin
de la guerre froide en 92 et s'il a été
mis en vigueur que dix ans plus tard
en réalité on voit bien qu'il s'agit
d'une mesure de confiance en autorisant
les pays de l'autre camp à faire des
survols de zone
mais naturellement après que l'agrément
a été donnée sur le plan de vol des
zones survolées ce que tu limite
évidemment l'intérêt de la chose puisque
les pays survolés et est averti et doit
être d'accord
alors on peut regretter aussi que ce
traité n'est pas évolué pour couvrir
aussi les conflits régionaux et pour
ouvrir des défis plus récents comme le
réchauffement climatique ou comme les
enjeux environnementaux
ce trait retrait américain porte il un
coup à l'architecturé de sécurité
européenne oui d'une certaine manière
parce que c'est l'indication qu'une une
partie de l'establishment sécuritaire
américains remettent en cause tout s'est
traité sur le désarmement qui ont été
construits qui ont été construits
longuement depuis l'époque de l'union
soviétique
alors tout le monde dit que la future
administration américaine reviendra
probablement à cette école du hameau nce
control mais il n'est pas sûr qu'elle y
revienne complètement et elle devra
tenir compte aussi des nouvelles
réalités
l'une de ces nouvelles réalités comme
disait john bolton le conseiller pour la
sécurité de trump lutte de ces réalités
c'est l'émergence de la chine dans le
domaine militaire et la chine a
maintenant des moyens à balistique
d'atteindre tous les pays d'europe et
d'atteindre peut-être même probablement
les états unis par conséquent il va
falloir mener une réflexion de ce type
et puis en europe bien sûr
l'architecturé de sécurité européenne
devra aussi être remise sur la table le
président de la république française a
lancé au fort de brégançon cette idée
d'une réflexion et la réflexion est
engagée sur le plan franco russe d'une
structure d'une du futur de
l'architecturé de confiance et de
sécurité en europe et par conséquent ce
retrait américain met le projecteur sur
cette reconstruction d'une architecture
de sécurité de confiance en europe
merci claude oble ans maison expert en
relations internationales
et dans le reste de l'actualité toujours
pas de répit pour la population au yémen
pays meurtri par des années de guerre au
rythme de bombardements massifs un
conflit qui rend toujours plus
dramatique des situations humanitaires
avec un notamment le nombre
d'hospitalisations d'enfants pour
malnutrition aiguë qui ne cesse
d'augmenter
le récit des lames medjahed l'oeil even
s'effondre en silence malgré ses larmes
et ses cris de bébés affamés dans
certaines régions du pays
un enfant sur cinq de moins de cinq ans
souffrent de malnutrition aiguë avec
même des records atteints dans le sud
diémé need une alerte lancée fin octobre
par les fonds des nations unies pour
l'enfance le yémen souffrent du problème
de la malnutrition à cause de la guerre
qui fait rage dans le pays depuis plus
de sept ans le problème de la sécurité
alimentaire est aujourd'hui l'une des
principales raisons pour lesquelles les
enfants sont vulnérables à la
malnutrition ainsi que les femmes
enceintes et allaitantes
denner complètement désemparé et obligé
parfois d'emmener leurs enfants dans des
hôpitaux pour une alimentation par sonde
[Musique]
ma vie est très malade et j'ai dû vendre
une bonbonne de gaz pour la transporter
à l'hôpital
son père n'a pas de travail mon enfant
est dans cet état à cause du manque de
nourriture et on n'a rien parce qu'on ne
peut pas travailler et il n'y a aucune
solution elle moment ce pas parié star a
même enchaîné 1
rahimi venir pour prendre soin de la
petite rafah la famille peut compter sur
une équipe médicale qui travaillent sans
relâche et fait souvent face à un manque
colossal de moyens de tous les cas que
nous traitons environ 25 à 35 des cas de
malnutrition
avec malheureusement des qualifications
parfois escalade du conflit déclin
économique sans compter les impacts
dévastateurs de la pandémie de covile 19
le yémen fait face à la pire crise
humanitaire au monde pour l'unicef les
programmes de traitement de la
malnutrition sont également menacés si
des fonds supplémentaires ne sont pas
reçus rapidement pour pouvoir renforcer
d'urgence et programme les nations unies
disent avoir besoin de plus de 50
millions de dollars
et le temps presse au yémen puisque près
de cent mille enfants de moins de 5 ans
risque actuellement de mourir de
malnutrition aiguë sévère reste avec
nous dans quelques instants nous
parlerons de l'allocution attendu
d'eminem écran demain soir le président
qui doit donner à le cap aux français
face au co vite des mesures d'allègement
qui sont espérés puis nous développerons
la polémique sur avenir lycéens en
syndicat a accusé d'avoir été modelée
par jean michel blanquer
[Musique]
quand vous voyez ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui avec cette deuxième vague
avec ce deuxième au film en est ce qu'on
pouvait faire autrement plus vous
dépister - les gens meurent et ça a été
vu en allemagne quatre fois moins de
morts qu'en france ça a été vu en
autriche 4 fois moins de morts qu'on
pense à aider vu en corée du sud etc
ça ne profite pas de cette deuxième
paiement pour dépister systématiquement
de les choses vont recommencer
il aura une troisième vague au printemps
et un troisième confinement et ce pays
sera évidemment cloués au sol
[Musique]
il n'y a pas une façon plus une pauvre
de défendre un système que de dire qu'il
est moins pire que notre peuple
c'était une volonté collectés vous le
savez comme moi que dès qu'on dit il n'y
a pas d'alternative on sort du politique
il est clair que tout le monde attend ça
est-ce que c'est grave
est ce que c'est normal si on veut
sauver la vie sur terre il est probable
qu'il faille prendre un certain nombre
de mesures un peu autoritaire c'est
intéressant on comprend que vous soyez
des sous les libéraux l'uniforme c'est
quand même des hommes comment ces
mecs-là arrive à dormir la nuit là aussi
je pense qu'on a vécu quelque chose
d'inusité gilet jaune c'était des
valeurs de droite
c'était des gens qui travaillent c'est
des gens qui avaient envie de
transmettre quelque chose à leurs
enfants
tout
le droit il doit éviter les dérives
idéologiques merci de le souligner
comment peut-on reconstituer une sixième
république qui ne soit pas un à l'oubli
parlementaire ça se passe en direct
puisque on est en direct
il y a quand même la liberté je vous
remercie de m'avoir invité
[Musique]
certains disent que nous ne sommes pas
une chaîne française
d'autres affirment même que nous ne
sommes pas journalistes mais vous
[Musique]
savez-vous vraiment qui nous sommes
les valeurs que nous défendons la
liberté
la liberté d'expression et d'opinion
nous défendons l'égalité l'égalité des
chances pour tous
[Musique]
nous sommes une équipe
nous sommes cette diversité qui fait la
france
et nous en sommes fiers
[Musique]
et si vous veniez voir par vous même
haifa j'ai entendu parler de wikileaks
et de julian assange pour la première
fois quand j'ai vu les images filmées
depuis l'hélicoptère en irak a tiré et
je pense qu'il ya des gens dans l'armée
américaine qui ne lui ont jamais
pardonné
je ne suis pas pour la peine de mort et
puisque je ne suis pas pour la peine de
mort
il n'a qu'une chose à faire abattre ce
fils de pute illégalement c'était
historique
il n'est pas d'avoir un journaliste
indépendant
un type avec son ordinateur révélant des
crimes de guerre à un large public
l'idée de développer une boîte de dépôts
numériques anonymes ont un lien avec le
média qu'est wikileaks
c'est une vraie nouveauté mais je
n'avais pas prévu qu'il deviendra
célèbre dans le monde entier si vite
qu'il serait à la tête de l'une des plus
puissantes organisations médiatiques du
monde avait il avait beaucoup de
jalousie dans les médias traditionnels
envers wikileaks est en vert assange en
particulier pourquoi n'est-il pas plus
comme donc ils l'ont accusée d' étaler
des excréments sur les murs noirs
ce qui est fou
et du hall 1 julian assange et à
l'isolément dans une prison de haute
sécurité attendant peut-être une
sentence d'emprisonnement à perpétuité
alors je ne veux pas le voir mourir dans
une prison américaine
je crois que c'est le sort qui l'attend
comme on a tous je donne en europe pas
seulement le cinéma
ils sont le cinéma
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
charles pathé a le génie des affaires
léon gaumont est un ingénieur surdoué
ces deux hommes que tout oppose et se
sont forgé une destinée commune dans une
perpétuelle surenchère ils ont bâti
chacun leur empire et dominer le monde
[Musique]
et
j'ai fort potentiel programme - et je
ferai que s'excuser voiture et un robot
mimoun et des viennes être humain je
vous emmène découvrir les robots les
plus high tech qui vont bientôt sortir
de leur laboratoire pour rentrer dans
nos maisons
[Musique]
hu l'air des robots approche nous avons
l'opportunité de pouvoir changer le
monde
ceux-ci excitant ils vont changer notre
manière de nous divertir d'apprendre le
communiqué en fait il y avait changé
notre vie
[Musique]
à guayaquil tous les cimetières
cliniques et hôpitaux sont saturés et
pour aller dans un cimetière
vous verrez beaucoup de gens attendre
pour enterrer leurs proches je pense
qu'ils ont au moins résolu le problème
des corps dans les rues au cours des
deux premières semaines les choses
étaient comme ça dans la majorité des
pays dits développés avec la
commercialisation des soins de la santé
le système de santé n'est pas en mesure
de faire face à ce problème et demandez
vous comment vais-je survivre comment
vais-je me protéger les etats-unis ont
mis en place un embargo très strictes
sur la syrie nous n'avons rien nous
manquons de tout je parle de matériel
médical les dealers donc a pointé leurs
armes sur les gens et dire rentrez chez
vous mais elle est nulle part leurs
affaires en dépendent
israël utilise une technologie qui
permet d'accéder aux informations
privées des gens depuis leur téléphone
portable et voir leurs déplacements
ainsi ils peuvent voir si vous avez
croisé une personne infectée par le
coronavirus et si c'est le cas ils vous
envoient immédiatement message et nous
avait croisé un individu testé positif
merci de vous mettre en confinement chez
vous
[Musique]
mais je pense que la chose la plus
intéressante est que tous les gens dans
le monde sont dans la même situation il
de cette situation
[Musique]
21h heure française merci nous rejoindre
pour cette deuxième heure d'émission
tout de suite voici les titres de
l'actualité de ce lundi 23 novembre
des tentes montées dans la capitale
plusieurs centaines de personnes tentent
d'installer un camp de migrants place de
la république à paris
une opération organisée par
l'association des dom iguerande utopia
56 les forces de l'ordre interviennent
en ce moment pour dénoncer ce qu en
cours d'installation
on sera en direct sur place dans
quelques instants avec notre reporter
bassin chebbi les journalistes mobilisés
en cause la proposition de la loi
relative à la sécurité globale jugé
attentatoire au droit d'informer et est
la liberté d'expression gérald darmanin
rencontrer en fin d'après midi leurs
représentants mais la réunion s'est
soldée par un échec
certains participants on appelle au
premier ministre à la veille de la mise
au vote de ce texte très controversé
jean michel blanquer a également sous le
feu des critiques avec des révélations
de presse sur le syndicat à venir
lycéens selon le quotidien libération
l'association aurait été montée de
toutes pièces au ministère de
l'éducation nationale pour servir sa
communication
médiapart de son côté révélé le 9
novembre que le syndicat dilapidé une
bonne partie des 65 mille euros de
subventions publiques en frais de bouche
dispense yeux notamment le ministre se
défend parlant d'une affaire je suit
autour de rien
et puis en algérie l'opposition accusé
manuel macron d'ingérence à la suite
d'un entretien accordé à l'hebdomadaire
jeune afrique publié vendredi dernier
dans ses colonnes le président français
salue le courage de son homologue
algérien abdel majid des bulls
hospitalisé en allemagne après avoir
contracté le qu'ovide et promet de faire
tout son possible pour l'aider dans la
période de transition que vit le pays
[Musique]
et on commence donc avec cette opération
our place de la république à paris
l'installation d'un camp migrants vous
le voyez sur ces images en direct des
tentes ont été déployés sur place
plusieurs associations sont présents
dont utopia 56 à l'origine de
l'opération les forces de l'ordre sont
déployées on retrouve tout de suite en
direct sur place notre reporter baisse
chez be bassem vous êtes donc sur cette
place de la république et les forces de
l'ordre qui ont entrepris de démanteler
ce camp migrants qui s'installe et à
peine
[Musique]
effectivement c'est fanny les forces de
l'ordre essaient de démanteler ce camp
de migrants un camp de migrants qui a
été un fait ici place de la république
dans les alentours de 19 heures une
opération menée par différentes
associations suite au démantèlement du
camp de migrants de saint denis c'était
mardi dernier le but des associations
c'est de se faire entendre de rendre
visible la situation critique de ces
migrants et bien sûr d'alerter les
pouvoirs publics des associations
présentes mais aussi des avocats et des
élus il ya eu avec quelques tensions
entre les forces de l'ordre et pis les
différentes associations comme vous
pouvez voir juste derrière moi sur ces
images est pour l'instant le calme est
revenu mais les associations les
associations pardon sont bien décidés à
rester sur place pour se faire entendre
pour l'instant la police n'arrive pas à
bien sûr à démanteler ce camp cette
position qui a été mise en place est ici
sur la place de la république je vous
rappelle que les maïs dernier c'est un
camp de saint denis qui logeait 1500
migrants de 800 d'entre eux sont restés
encore sur place les autres essayent
tant bien que mal de trouver une
solution et surtout un abri dans la
capitale les associations essayent de
leur trouver une solution mais aucune
solution pour l'instant proposé par le
gouvernement d'où cette opération menée
par l'association utopia pour alerter
les pouvoirs publics est pour l'instant
le calme est revenu mais associations
sont toujours présentes les avocats
également et des élus afin de venir en
aide à ces migrants pour leur trouver
une solution bien sûr on va rester sur
place ici place de la république pour
suivre cette opération menée par des
forces de l'ordre et de revenir bien sûr
dans les prochaines éditions pour vous
en dire plus sur la situation ici place
de la république
merci donc en direct de la place de la
république et si la situation devait
évoluer n'hésitez pas à nous rappeler
merci à vous
la proposition de loi relative à la
sécurité globale jugé attentatoire au
droit d'informer est la liberté
d'expression par les journalistes la
réunion entre gérald darmanin et les
représentants a pris une tournure
inattendue
le syndicat national des journalistes
les avocats associations et artistes qui
se sont rendus au ministère de
l'intérieur en fin d'après midi
l issue de la réunion gérald darmanin
devait donner une conférence de presse
il n'a pas eu lieu finalement les
représentants des journalismes ce n'est
pas entendre ont quitté qui ne se
faisait pas entendre quitté
volontairement cette réunion je vous
propose d'écouter leurs conclusions en
tirer nous avons posé avant tous ces
préalables là pour toute discussion pour
avancer c'est à dire le retrait de
l'article 21 le retrait de l'article 22
24 et du nouveau schéma du maintien de
l'ordre
on a un ministre qui nous a endormis qui
veut essayer oui de modifier par ci par
là quelques améliorations il n'en est
pas question donc nous avons décidé
collectivement de quitter la réunion et
nous en appelons à monsieur le premier
ministre
jean castex madame marlène schiappa
ministre délégué auprès du ministre de
l'intérieur vient ainsi de confirmer ce
jour sur rmc que tout journaliste qui
diffusera des images d'un membre des
forces de l'ordre en train de commettre
une violence policière pourra être
renvoyé devant un tribunal correctionnel
cela implique qu'il pourra être
immédiatement arrêtés au moment d'un
direct menotté placé en garde à vue
et ce même si la justice décidé de ne
pas le poursuivre voire de le relaxer la
dérive autoritaire de monsieur le
ministre de l'intérieur et des
parlementaires
initiateur de ce texte cette réponse de
clientéliste à certains syndicats de
police portent une atteinte directe à
l'exercice de nos professions et aux
droits fondamentaux de douze citoyens et
le ministre de l'intérieur a préféré
réagir sur twitter en postant une vidéo
en voici un extrait cette proposition
doit n'est pas fini si j'ose dire
dans son étude parce qu'il ira au sénat
dans quelques mois il reviendra à
l'assemblée nationale c'est l'article 24
vise à trouver un point d'équilibré
entre la
légitime liberté d'information la
liberté de la presse qui doit être
totale et puis la protection de nos
policiers et nos gendarmes qui dans leur
vie privée sont parfois attaquer j'ai
rappelé et c'est apprend extrêmement
important que quiconque journalistes ou
non pourra continuer à filmer des
opérations de police bien évidemment les
forces de l'ordre ne pouvons pas
l'empêcher que bien évidemment ses
policiers et ses gendarmes ne pourrons
pas empêcher de diffuser ces images
elles pourront toujours être diffusés
sur les réseaux sociaux et sans flouter
le visage des policiers et des gens là
simplement nous devons protéger le
policier d'un drame
ils n'ont pas souhaité pour l'instant
continuer ses discussions ma porte est
toujours ouverte et jolie autant plus
que la liberté d'information la liberté
de la presse et les forces de l'ordre
sont les deux piliers de notre
démocratie de nos institutions et
l'article 24 de la loi sécurité globale
qui entend pénalisé je vous le rappelle
la diffusion malveillants l'image de
forces de l'ordre manifestation trouve
également ses détracteurs au sein même
de la majorité parlementaire
interrogé ce matin sur france bleu la
députée la m1 nathalie salle ne mâche
pas ses mots je ne la voterai pas car je
suis en opposition avec une grande
partie de ce texte nous allons
tranquillement vers un état autoritaire
vers une suppression des libertés
individuelles des libertés déjà mises à
mal par la période sanitaire avec le
confinement et les restrictions de
déplacement il faut donner un cadre de
protection des forces de l'ordre mais
cette loi va beaucoup trop loin
notamment l'article qui fait tant
polémique il faut préserver la liberté
d'expression dans notre pays d'autant
que le cadre juridique existe et pour en
parler nous sommes avec emmanuel vire
secrétaire général snj cgt bonsoy
emmanuelle vibert merci d'être avec nous
sur tesfran gérald darmanin qui a donc
reçu on l'a dit c'est représentant les
organisations et associations est ce que
vous y avez participé aujourd'hui si oui
quelles conclusions en tirez-vous
mais bon soir bien sûr j'y ai participé
en tant que secrétaire général du snj
cgt
il me semble que là ce que vous venez de
dire de montrer de la députée république
en marche qui ose affirmer enfin que
nous allons tranquillement vers un état
autoritaire voilà c'est monsieur
darmanin nous a donné une fin de non
recevoir
donc nous nous avons pris nos
responsabilités nous sommes dans une
coordination qui regroupe 70
organisations beaucoup plus large
d'ailleurs que les syndicats turin liste
1 il ya aussi la ligue des droits de
l'homme amnesty international
il ya beaucoup d'organisations de la
société monsieur darmanin n'a pas voulu
nous entendre
ça fait quatre ans que spécifiquement
les journalistes ont des problèmes avec
les forces de l'ordre lors des
manifestations
c'est le troisième ministre de
l'intérieur que nous voyons nous avons
d'abord vu monsieur cazenave en 2016
monsieur castaner en 2018 maintenant
monsieur d'arman il n'y a toujours pas
de réponses à nos interrogations et
surtout maintenant dit c'est une
véritable crise de défiance entre la
profession de journaliste est en tout
cas le ministère de l'intérieur et le
mini dans l'intérieur puisque nous pour
nous monsieur darmanin n'est plus ce
soir notre interlocuteur et nous en
appelons à monsieur castex emmanuel vire
à votre avis c'est pour cette raison
cette mésentente 700 non-recevoir qu'on
entend ce blocage que gérald darmanin a
passé la conférence de presse attendu ce
soir qu'il avait prévu de faire
évidemment on a bien on a bien senti
nous en étant présent sur place que
monsieur monsieur darmanin allait
essayer d' instrumentaliser cette
rencontre alors qu'il faut savoir c'est
déjà c'est une rencontre que nous
demandons depuis des mois des mois des
mois avant la publication du nouveau
schéma de maintien de l'ordre qui est
intervenue le 16 septembre
et je vous rappelle par exemple que
l'interpellation de notre confrère de
france télévisions lors de notre
première mobilisation mardi n'est pas dû
à la longue
la nouvelle proposition de loi sécurité
globale c'est bien un effet du nouveau
schéma de maintien de l'ordre
mis en place par monsieur darmanin le 16
septembre
comment vous expliquez qu'il vous reçoit
finalement la veille de l'adoption de la
loi par l'assemblée nationale ça
n'aurait pas dû être concerté un petit
peu avant en amont évidemment c'est ce
que nous lui avons dit il a essayé si
vous voulez pendant la réunion d'en
faire un problème spécifique des
syndicats de journalistes des
représentants du journaliste avec le
pouvoir
on n'en est plus là malheureusement nous
ça fait des mois je vous dis on l'avait
même demandé à monsieur castaner quand
il ya eu les problématiques de violences
pendant les manifestations de gilet
jaune aujourd'hui peut pas nous dire et
j'ai vu sa déclaration qu'il a fait pour
remplacer la conférence de presse sur
twitter en disant qu'il était très
attaché à la liberté de la presse
mais n'est ce pas le même ministre de
l'intérieur qui réclamé un floutage des
policiers tout le temps encore il ya une
dizaine de jours
donc quel est ce double discours de
monsieur darmanin je pense que la
pression de la rue commence à faire
réfléchir de ce monsieur d'harmonie mais
nous pour nous c'est trop tard c'est
maintenant a dit jean castex
quand on voit les difficultés dans la
majorité de la république en marche
c'est un monsieur castex d'arbitré et de
recevoir la coordination
alors ce qui pose problème on le
rappelle c'est cet article 24 dont on
parle beaucoup qui entend pénaliser la
diffusion malveillante de photographies
policiers lors de manifestations ça
voudrait dire que les journalistes
pourront filmer m'aimait pas diffuser
ces de d2 ça qu'il s'agit bien sûr mais
c'est surtout une fois de plus un risque
même d'autocensure des journalistes fins
et ont mais on n'arrête pas de mettre
des pressions sur les journalistes
c'est déjà un métier difficile et nous
ne disons pas que le métier de policier
n'est pas difficile sauf que en cas
d'atteinte et c'est ce que dit la
députée république en marche que vous
avez cités avant en cas d'atteinte quand
on veut porter atteinte à un policier
quand on porte atteinte à un policier
que ce soit par des films parmi tout ça
est déjà prévue par le code pénal
donc pourquoi en rajouter pour nous
c'est une pression supplémentaire sur le
libre exercice du métier de journaliste
un métier
qui est déjà mis sous pression depuis
des années par de multiples lois que ce
soit la loi sur le secret des affaires
la loi sur les fesses news ce que ce
soit les journalistes convoqués pour
qu'on essaie de de connaître leurs
sources
enfin on le sent bien et ce qu'on a
essayé de dire au ministre aujourd'hui
c'est qu'il regarde l'image de la france
à l'étranger
enfin bientôt à comparer la france à la
turquie à la hongrie on ne comprend plus
en tout cas la loi a suscité des
manifestations le conseil des droits de
l'homme de l'onu qui s'interroge sur le
contenu de cette loi la commission
européenne qui se réserve le droit de
vérifier la conformité du texte avec le
droit de l'union européenne ça fait
beaucoup à son compte et les critiques
effectivement des médias selon vous le
gouvernement petit ou même reculer sous
cette forme de pression après tron nous
c'est notre volonté est de toute façon
en tout cas le combat contre la
proposition de loi à sécurité de rêve
sera long parce que comme vous le savez
demain c'est une adoption à l'assemblée
nationale puis le texte partira au sénat
puis il y aura une saisine du conseil
constitutionnel parce que les les
groupes parlementaires de gauche de
l'opposition ont déjà annoncé qu'ils
saisiraient le conseil constitutionnel
donc pour nous nous sommes au début
d'une mobilisation et d'ailleurs qui va
se traduire puisque la réunion
d'aujourd'hui est un échec total
monsieur darmanin a pas plu nous entend
donc nous appelons samedi 28 novembre
samedi prochain à des mobilisations
partout en france nous allons organiser
des marches pour la liberté
merci manuel vire secrétaire général snj
cgt d'avoir été avec nous en direct sur
rt france pour parlait toujours de cette
loi sécurité merci à vous clore une
affaire qui n'a pas lieu d'être jean
michel blanquer réagi aux accusations de
libération et de mediapart sur le
syndicat à venir lycéens qui serait
téléguidé par le ministère de
l'éducation nationale pour en faire un
instrument de communication
gouvernementale subventions tollé
syndical commission denquête retour sur
ce début des eps faire avec moi ni d'avs
et nani
et hélène masquelier mediapart et
libération révèle d'une enquête
embarrassante pour le gouvernement
l'organisation lycéenne de 400 adhérents
peu connus jusqu'à l'or est soupçonné de
collusion avec le ministère de
l'éducation nationale
d'après ces révélations le syndicat qui
se revendique à politiques auraient été
créées en 2018 pour servir la
communication du gouvernement
mediapart affirme que le syndicat à
venir lycéens auraient bénéficié l'année
dernière d'une subvention de 65 mille
euros de la part du ministère de
l'éducation nationale une subvention
censée financer un congrès lequel n'a
jamais eu lieu
selon mediapart une grande partie de la
somme aurait été dépensés dans des bars
des hôtels de luxe ou pour l'achat de
matériel informatique
fin juillet jean michel blanquer re est
alerté mais le ministère de l'éducation
nationale décide tout de même de prévoir
une nouvelle subvention de 30000 euros
le jeune syndicat lui semble venir à
point nommé vous avez un syndic qui est
créée en décembre 2018
pile au moment des blocus pour dire que
la réforme du bac est une sainte
réformes au niveau du timing c'est
beaucoup trop visible il fallait essayer
de trouver une voie qui disent que la
réforme est bien d'avoir un mouvement
qui se revendique comme à partisans un
syndicat lycéen qu'on essaye de tourner
en notre faveur
libération révèle des liens de proximité
entre l'ancien numéro 2 du ministère et
les responsables d'avenir lycéens
l'article affirme aussi que des
rectorats aurait contribué à rédiger les
communiqué du syndicat
suite à ces révélations plusieurs élus
ont demandé l'ouverture d'une commission
d'enquêté parlementaire pour faire la
lumière sur les liens d'avenir lycéens
avec le pouvoir exécutif le ministère de
l'éducation nationale avait lancé une
enquête administrative consécutive aux
révélations de mediapart le 10 novembre
jean michel blanquer rni de son côté
toute tentative d'instrumentalisation
en réalité c'est un non-sujet montée en
épingle par le secteur de mithra gauche
pour des raisons qui leur appartiennent
voilà elle a eu une subvention
aujourd'hui le sujet c est ce que l on a
fait un mauvais usage
c'est dès que j'ai su qu'ils avaient un
éventuel problème on a diligenté une
enquête
cette enquête évidemment sont d'abord
les résultats manière complètement
transparente voilà le sujet de son côté
à venir lycéens affirment que ses
membres n'ont pas été manipulée et prône
le dialogue
les autres syndicats lycéens dénoncent
eux une propagande d'état est une
insulte faite aux jeunes et pour en
parler nous sommes avec une arrivée
laurent dry harisoa secrétaire du
mouvement national lycéens
bonsoir merci d'être avec nous en direct
sur rt france alors c'est presque
unanimement les organisations lycéennes
qui crient au scandale
selon vous il ya des éléments concrets
il prouve la connivence entre cette
association et le ministère comme
l'affirment la presse bah écoute et déjà
du côté de gnl on a une certitude c'est
qu'à venir lycéens népal à courir comme
par hasard cette association apparaît
pendant les mobilisations et 2018 des
lycéennes et je sais pas s'il vous
remettez en question les les sujets les
articles de libération et de mediapart
mais bon à mon avis c'est quand même une
affaire très sérieuse
qu'est ce qui vous fait dire ça bah
écoutez donner de l'argent à des lycées
à les subventionner
je vais juste vous dire quelque chose en
tête cette association donc qui est
apparue en décembre 2018 a été
subventionné pour l'année 2009 soit une
année après sa création
aucun autre syndicaliste a eu sa peau m
-nl on existe depuis 2016 notre
subvention elle a dix mille euros ont
pour 2019 et elle a été à zéro euro pour
2020 alors que là il ya soixante cinq
mille euros c'est ça de subventions
d'ailleurs le syndicat est lui aussi a
accusé cette fois ci par mediapart
d'avoir dilapidé ses subventions en
frais de bouche dispense eu en hôtel de
luxe
quoi qu'il en soit il s'agit de deux
somme assez importante par rapport c'est
ce que vous nous expliquer aux
subventions que reçoivent normalement
les syndicats étudiants ou lycéens
bien entendu bien entendu nous a une
elle remettra jamais la faute sur les
lycéens parce qu'ils ont été manipulés
par un gouvernement
je comprends pas comment jean michel
bleu blanc caire peut encore se regarder
dans le miroir en ayant sur la
conscience qu'il est donné de l'argent à
des mineurs pour servir son propre
intérêt pour avoir ses propres
interlocuteur c'est un scandale c'est
honteux
aujourd'hui vous en tant que syndicat
lycéen vous avez envie de réagir comment
quelle est votre marge de manoeuvre
parce que c'est une affaire délicate
pour le moment il n'y a pas de preuve
c'est ce qu'affirme voilà le journal
libération aujourd'hui on imagine qu'une
enquête n'a pas encore été menée donc
c'est toujours à manier avec beaucoup de
prudence et accusations évidemment bien
entendu il faut savoir que de notre côté
du côté des syndicats lycéens d'extrême
gauche à je reprends les propos de notre
cher ministre
on se prend des pressions parce que ils
veulent retourner la commission contre
nous mais là je vais faire un message
joubert si jamais jamais c'est si jamais
jean michel blanquer on ne regarde jean
michel blanquer on n'a pas peur on est
prêt à faire partie de cette commission
si on n'a rien à cacher on n'est pas
comme vous alors on comprend qu'il ya
quand même des petits règlements de
compte
voilà entre les syndicats qui on le
rappelle c'est aussi intéressant pour
nos téléspectateurs parce qu'on doit
être objectifs sont sont souvent
politisé également vous ne vous en
cachez pas vous même
c'est jean-michel bloquèrent qui a tenu
de tels propos moi je peux vous dire
qu'au sein des mesnel on a des on a des
jeunes de tout horizon de milieux
populaires de milieux un petit peu plus
bourgeois on a aussi des hommes
fan on a de la diversité c'est ça en
fait qui fait un syndicat on n'est pas
derrière un seul parti on est derrière
aucun parti d'ailleurs ce sont juste les
idéaux qu'il nous faut qu'ils nous
tiennent debout alors pour le moment à
venir lycéens le syndicat remis en cause
mis en cause plutôt défend son
indépendance et ne met en cause à aucun
moment le ministère vous avez quand même
confiance en vos collègues étudiants
bah écoutez moi ce que je peux vous dire
c'est qu'à finaliser un depuis sa
création a eu beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup
de démission c'est du jamais vu dans
l'histoire du syndicalisme policière
donc c'est pas anodin à mon avis merci
en harivelo randrianarisoa secrétaire du
mouvement national lycéens merci d'avoir
été avec nous en direct sur rt france à
la veille de d'allocutions télévisées d'
emmanuel macron les commerçants lyonnais
ont manifesté aujourd'hui pour réclamer
la réouverture de leurs magasins ils
étaient près de deux mille selon les
organisateurs envahir les rues du vieux
lyon lyon il s'agit du troisième
rassemblement ce genre depuis le début
du second confinement objectif mettre la
pression sur le chef de l'état pour une
réouverture rapide des petits commerces
et un allègement des restrictions ont
écorné depuis neuf mois
hier
alors d'aujourd'hui on est toujours en
attente on leur avait proposé un
protocole avec nos syndicats
ils ont même pas lui aussi à le regarder
à l'heure d'aujourd'hui vous avez des
fêtes sauvages qui seront partout dans
des appartements privés dans des
villages donc oui on attend qu'il y soit
enfin on espère
qui va enfin pouvoir nous écouter alors
on attend à ce que l'annoncent bien
évidemment très heureux que la plupart
des commerces puissent réouvrir mais moi
je suis aussi chef de cuisine et
j'aimerais que le président annonce une
réouverture pour les restaurants et je
n'ose même pas croire ce qui est dit
dans certains médias que la réouverture
pour nous serait au mois de janvier
la convention citoyenne pour le climat
avaient voté pour la création d'un crime
déco side ce ne sera finalement qu'un
délit le gouvernement à ce texte prévoit
un texte qui considère donc comme délit
toutes atteintes graves à
l'environnement inscrire dans le code
pénal ces contrevenants encourront
jusqu'à dix ans d'emprisonnement les
précisions d'hélèna sculier le ministre
de la justice annonce dans le jdd la
création du délit d' écocide dérivés
d'une proposition de la convention
citoyenne pour le climat le texte vise à
prévenir et à sanctionner les atteintes
graves à l'environnement
mais la proposition gouvernementale se
révèle moins ambitieuse que le crime d'
écocide que les 150 citoyens tirés au
sort voulait instaurer en le portant au
même rang qu'un crime contre l'humanité
et un crime déco site serait plus
symbolique incluant le fait de porter
atteinte à la nature d'une manière
menaçant la survie des écosystèmes et du
vivant même si c'est une amélioration du
droit à saluer là encore le sans filtre
et piétiné la proposition qui sera
présenté aux députés est infiniment
moins ambitieuse que celle portée par la
convention citoyenne et ne correspond
pas aux définitions international de
l'écocide selon le texte prévu par le
gouvernement de delhi seront créé le
délit génère
de pollution et celui de mise en danger
de l'environnement le premier prévoit
des sanctions modulée en fonction de
l'intentionnalité de l'auteur pouvant
aller de trois à dix ans de réclusion et
des amendes d'un montant maximum de 4 5
millions d'euros pour ce qui est de la
mise en danger délibérée de
l'environnement les sanctions pourront
s'appliquer y compris quand la pollution
n'a pas encore eu lieu
la peine serait alors d'un an de prison
et 200 mille euros damende pour faire
appliquer ce nouveau texte eric
dupond-moretti prévoit des juridictions
spécialisées de l'environnement dans
toutes les cours d'appel et de donner le
statut de policier judiciaire à des
agents de la biodiversité
pour certains ce type de délit existe
déjà dans les codes de l'environnement
et il suffirait alors de les sanctionner
davantage pour d'autres juristes cette
modification du droit interne se
révélerait tout simplement inefficaces
sans un soutien du droit pénal
international dans tous les cas avec
cette mesure le gouvernement français se
conforme à la directive de l'union
européenne sur la protection de
l'environnement par le droit pénal qui
date de 2008 reste avec nous dans
quelques instants nous parlerons de
l'algérie après les déclarations d'
emmanuel macron qui promet de tout faire
pour soutenir le président thé moon
une partie de l'opposition algérienne
crie à l' ingérence et puis direction le
burkina faso l'élection présidentielle
s'est tenue sous la menace d'attaqués
djihadistes empêchant environ 300 milles
burkinabé de voter
[Musique]
la chasse est un lobby donc il pèse très
lourd il faut arrêter de dire que on a
besoin des chasseurs qu'on a besoin de
régulation on n'a jamais eu la preuve de
ça cette réduction du débat justement
entre le tout blanc a le tout noir ne
nuit-elle pas finalement à l'idée même
que les français pour espère de la
chasse je crois pas que ce soit réduire
le débat de rappeler que c'est un
plaisir qui va jusqu'à la mort cc c'est
ça l'essentiel et c'est pour ça que
c'est un sujet très très épidermique
parce que s'ils une histoire de vie et
de mort il faut protéger la végétation
pour protéger la faune il faut protéger
notre santé
tout ça c y et n'oublions pas tous nos
problèmes viennent du mépris qu'on a sur
le reste du monde vivant donc il faut il
faut arrêter de laisser les chasseurs
faire leur bêtise et je suis poli
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose une
convention admise par tous s'il arrive
quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins ou
du bon vieux cash vous parlerons de tout
sans langue de bois
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le 4 octobre dernier la nouvelle
calédonie à voter sur son avenir avec ou
sans la france et pour la deuxième fois
le nom à l'indépendance a emporté avec
53 26 % alors qu'il était à 56,4 au
premier plan après le troisième
référendum en 2022 le maintien dans la
france où l'indépendance déboucheront
forcément retour des troubles importants
créé par les perdre au lieu de chercher
des arguments introuvable pour faire
gagner clairement sous l'heure
n'est-elle pas au dialogue pour
concevoir un projet commun à l'ensemble
des signataires des accords de nous mais
que se passera-t-il quand le retour
légales et obligatoires au suffrage
universel montrera que la majorité est
toujours contre l'indépendance par
il n'y a pas une façon plus pauvres de
défendre un système que de dire qu'il
est moins pire que notre peuple
c'était une volonté collectés vous le
savez comme moi qui dès qu'on dit il n'y
a pas d'alternative on sort du celtic
il est clair que tout le monde attend ça
est-ce que c'est grave
est ce que c'est normal si on veut
sauver la vie sur terre il est probable
qu'il faille prendre un certain nombre
de mesures un peu autoritaire c'est
intéressant on comprend que vous soyez
déçu l'univers l'uniforme c'est quand
même des hommes comment ces mecs-là
arrive à dormir la nuit là aussi je
pense qu'on a vécu quelque chose d'inouï
gilet jaune c'était des valeurs de
droite
c'était des gens qui travaillent c'est
les gens qui avaient envie de
transmettre quelque chose à leurs
enfants qui
le droit il doit éviter les dérives
idéologiques merci de le souligner
comment peut-on reconstituer une sixième
république qui ne soit pas l'oublié
parlementaire ça se passe en direct
puisque on est en direct il ya quand
même la liberté
je vous remercie de m'avoir invité
[Musique]
j'ai fort dans ses organes moi et je
ferai tout ce que tu veux toi tu es un
robot mimoun et des viennes être humain
je vous emmène découvrir les robots les
plus high tech qui vont bientôt sortir
de leur laboratoire pour rentrer dans
nos maisons
appelé malus
[Musique]
l'ère des robots approche nous avons
l'opportunité de pouvoir changer le
monde
ceux-ci excitant ils vont changer notre
manière de nous divertir d'apprendre de
communiqué en fait il y avait changé
notre vie
[Musique]
21h30 heure française soyez les
bienvenus en direct sur rt france en
algérie l'opposition accuse emmanuel
macron d'ingérence cela fait suite à un
entretien du président français est
accordée à l'hebdomadaire jeune afrique
est publiée vendredi dernier dans les
colonnes de ce magazine il salue le
courage de son homologue algérien d'elle
la magie tebboune actuellement
hospitalisé en allemagne après avoir
contracté les coronavirus il promet de
faire tout son possible pour l'aider
dans la période de transition que vit le
pays
alors comment interpréter ces propos d'
emmanuel macron qui ont mis en rage
l'opposition pourquoi provoque-t-il un
tel tollé
peut-on parler d'ingérence oui ou non de
néo colonialisme comme le disent
certains c'est l'objet de notre face à
face ce soir
[Musique]
et pour en parler nous sommes en direct
avec souad baba aïssa vice-présidente de
la dalle à l'errance des démocrates de
la diaspora algérienne bonsoir madame
merci d'être avec nous en direct
regarder france à vos côtés le général
dominique trinquant expert en
géostratégie ancien chef de la mission
militaire française auprès de l'onu
bonsoir général trinquant remercie
également d'être avec nous alors je le
disais en introduction c'est donc une
petite phrase d'emmanuel macron dans les
colonnes du magazine jeune afrique qui a
donc fait polémique de l'autre côté de
la méditerranée je vous propose de
regarder tout d'abord je vous le dis
franchement je ferai tout mon possible
pour aider l'eau prise d'antenne boon
dans cette période de transition
il est courageux on ne change pas un
pays des institutions et des structures
de pouvoir en quelques mois il faut tout
faire pour que cette transition
réussisse je ferai tout mon possible
pour aider le président tebboune c'est
cette phrase soit baysa qui ne passe pas
expliqué nous mais écoutez moi je
voudrais dire que je n'aurais pas la
vision étroite d'un nationalisme qui dès
qu'une personne s'exprime sur l'algérie
crie à l' ingérence mais je me pense que
là nous sommes pas un président de la
république française qui fait vraiment
une immixion est vraiment une immixion
qu'on appellerait plutôt une ingérence
politique en disant qu'il apporte tout
son soutien à monsieur tebboune qui est
un président qui a été nommé par un
système politique que ce système
politique est entièrement refusé par le
peuple algérien qui est dans la rue
depuis le 12 février 2019
le 22 février 2010 9 mm avant et qui dit
bien qu'il veut un changement politique
et monsieur tebboune n'a pas la figure
n'a pas le visage de quelqu'un qui
représente cette transition démocratique
puisque les élections du 12 décembre
2019 ont rejeté le scrutin
c'est un homme qui a été nommé par à
pouvoir politique et le pouvoir
militaire puisque nous savons danse
pays en tout cas nous avons une armée à
qui appartient le pays et que cet état
il ce peuple lui cette armée qui est là
et qui l'empêchent d'avancer et de
changer politiquement et quand il dit
qu'il apporte tout son soutien à
monsieur tebboune dans cette transition
nous aimerions savoir de quelle
transition il parle parce que les
élections liés à cette espèce de à ce
pseudo référendum sur un changement de
constitution a été aussi rejeté par le
peuple
et ce n'est pas avec un pourcentage de 4
% d'électeurs on arrive à assortir à un
pourcentage de 66 % de oui au référendum
est de faire croire à un plébiscite
donc ne nous avons consciemment pris
cette phrase en main parce qu'elle
démontre que aujourd'hui ce pouvoir a
peur et qu'il est en train de chercher
des légitimités et que monsieur le
président de la république française
emmanuel macron est en train d'apporter
de la légitimité à un pouvoir qui ne
doit pas en avoir
alors que depuis son arrivée il y à une
répression incroyable et on en reparlera
je pense tout au long de ce débat on va
en parler effectivement soit de bailly
ça quand on écoute les propos c'est bien
expliqué de votre interlocutrice général
train quand le contexte algérien on a
suivi ici même sur cette antenne
alors que cet ancien fidèle d'abdelaziz
bouteflika n'est pas très apprécié des
algériens on peut comprendre quand même
une légitimité dans cette colère est ce
que emmanuel macron a fait un revirement
maintenant je pense je pense qu'il faut
aller jusqu'où re au bout des mots et le
mot de transition est très intéressant
si le président me croit a utilisé le
mot de transition c'est qui c'est que
l'algérie est dans une phase de
transformation et qu'actuellement le
président teboul et représentants de
cette transition
on est si vous voulez en algérie un
petit peu comme dans le cas au liban si
vous me permet
et de révolution qui sont d'ailleurs
très respectable qui en algérie en
particulier se sont très bien passées
avec des manifestations pacifiques sur
la place qui contestent le pouvoir en
place qui a amené d'ailleurs un
changement en algérie à ce moment-là
peut-être pas à la hauteur de ce que
souhaitait les gens qui manifestaient
dans la rue mais le problème c'est que
la manifestation dans la rue ne débouche
pas sur une proposition sur un parti qui
puisse prendre le pouvoir et changer
radicalement les choses donc aujourd'hui
eh bien écoutez le pouvoir il est ce
qu'il est il est parfaitement
contestable je comprends madame qui le
contestent ce que je veux dire
simplement c'est que il est celui là
aujourd'hui et le président la crau part
d'un pouvoir de transition
parce qu'il a la france a besoin de la
stabilité en algérie pour des tas de
raisons aussi bien à cause de ce qui se
passe au sud de l'algérie que ce qui se
passe à l'intérieur de l'algérie voit de
ce qui se passe en france 2 qu'elle a
peu
elle a besoin de stabilité maintenant
c'est aux algériens de changer le le
gouvernement et l'espace politique
or j'ai l'impression je le répète que
c'est comme au liban il ya des
manifestations mais qui ne débouchent
pas sur des changements soin de soi de
baba aïssa pourquoi le monde quand même
d'un g oui alésien les i je vous en prie
répondait oui oui je vais répondre
justement alors je veux bien entendre le
mot transition change et là d'un seul
coup en transformation ya une différence
entre transformation si j'étais dans un
état démocratique
or nous quand on utilise le mot
transition ça veut dire que monsieur le
président de la république française
emmanuel macron considère que monsieur
tebboune et son gouvernement sont le
visage de la transition
or si je suis dans un état de droit et
que je suis dans un mouvement de
soulèvement populaire et révolutionnaire
la transition passe par un processus de
constituante
il me semble pas puisque comme le dit
monsieur emmanuel macron qu' il faut du
temps pour changer les institutions
pourquoi voulez vous
caen - dun en émerge un parti politique
alors que c'est un pays qui a souffert
dans les années 90 du terrorisme
islamiste et qui a souffert depuis
soixante ans de ce conte son opposition
soient toujours muselé et nous savons
très bien que si il émerger une
quelconque personne toute chute il y
aurait de la répression puisque
d'ailleurs ce qui se passe actuellement
depuis ce mouvement révolutionnaire et
depuis que monsieur tebboune est aux
manettes c'est que des jeunes sont mis
en prison
monsieur emmanuel macron qui se vante
d'être le chantre de la liberté
d'expression ne rappelle pas à celui
qu'il considère être son homologue
d'avoir le respect de la liberté
d'expression alors que acac rica tuerie
smooth nîmes est en prison alors que des
journalistes des médecins des citoyens
et des citoyennes lambda sont en prison
et que dans un pays comme la france où
l'on parle de laïcité on à monsieur
yacine mebarki qui a eu dix ans de
prison pour apologie à la laïcité
est-ce que nous sommes dans un état de
droit est-ce que l'on peut parler au
monde c'est un débat on va laisser
répondre justement le général trinquons
qui avait pas l'air très d'accord non
pas du tout parce que ce que vous dites
madame si vous demandez au président
macron à ce moment là de faire de
l'entrisme sur la politique algérienne à
ce moment là on pourra l'accuser
effectivement mais aujourd'hui les
cartes sont dans les mains du peuple
algérien et si le peuple algérien ne
peut pas changer le gouvernement en
faisant des manifestations sur la place
que voulez vous qu'il fasse le président
français il va pas soulever la
population curieuse on n'a pas demandé
au président français ce que lui
pardonnez moi j'essaye d'apporter de
l'eau au moulin de ce débat mais c'est
vrai de proposer de l'aide
macron le fais pas pour chaque pays il
ya des intérêts peut-être géostratégique
enjeu important entre la france et
l'algérie allait venir j'allais y venir
nous savons très bien que l'algérie est
un pays où la géostratégie avec assaël
g5 comme on l'appelle entre la
mauritanie le mali le sahara occidental
et cetera la libye la tunisie le maroc
nous savons très bien qu'il y a des
intérêts géostratégiques et aujourd'hui
ses intérêts géostratégiques ne s'arrête
pas qu'au gaz et au pétrole
ils ont ils vont même plus plus loin
puisque c'est quand même la raie aux
frontières de tout ce qui bouge qui
pourrait arriver en france comme
l'immigration clandestine
donc vous voyez que c'est les armes
c'est tout ce qu'il ya de ce côté là
d'un point de vue géostratégique qui ne
s'arrête pas simplement à l'économique
caisse à ses intérêts du président
macron parce que la géostratégie la
sécurité de la france et le c'est la
mission première du président mâcon la
politique intérieure de la guérit élevé
des citoyens algériens voilà que wipro
congé de la politique pour chanter les
jours que tu es aussi et la politique
étrangère aussi est aux algériens et aux
algériennes elles ne se paie pas
simplement dans les salons à l'elysée et
au quai d'orsay
derrière le dos et les intérêts des
algériens et des algériennes à oran
algérie ça fait bondir comme vous sur ce
plateau chère madame regarder ce qu'on
dit notamment le président du
rassemblement pour la culture et la
démocratie avance une belle abattent sur
sa page facebook
emmanuel macron s'exerce à administrer
des leçons de démocratie et de
gouvernance
ils se croient autorisés à distribuer
des certificats de légitimité aux
dirigeants des indigènes que nous sommes
ceci n'est pas une simple ingérence mais
la révélation que la france est aux
manettes d'une feuille de route pour
notre pays
général trinquant vraiment vous ne
comprenez pas cette voix lasse on dit on
dit tout et n'importe quoi
madame monsieur
accuse le président d'ingérence madame
demande au président d'intervenir sur la
politique algérienne
ce qui serait de l'ain je rappelle que
la politique algérienne c'est aux
algériens de la régler et la france ses
intérêts géostratégiques un petit air de
transformer pas mais je n'ai jamais
demandé à monsieur emmanuel macron de
s'ingérer dans la politique algérienne
je lui ai demandé justement de ne pas
porter son son soutien à un président
qui est illégitime et que tout un peuple
refuse parce que de toute façon nous
sommes aujourd'hui avec à pouvoir
politique qui n'a pas changé depuis 60
ans c'est le même système politique et
qui est soutenu aujourd'hui sous des
travers néocolonialistes et non pas
colonialiste comme il y a quelques
années et que ce néocolonialisme les
algériens et les algériennes ne sont pas
prêts à l'accepter et que leur s'il le
perd s'il ya eu 1 0 ce qu'ils auraient à
faire c'est peut-être une ingérence et
de rappeler à son homologue qu'il doit
respecter à qu'il doit respecter ce que
réclame un peuple quand il demanda à un
système politique de dégager le tir le
peuple qui s'exprime dans la rue aux
quais et le peuple est en train de se
préparer aux besoins des manifestations
on ne le voit pas beaucoup ailleurs en
algérie générale 5 ans s'il vous plaît
merci beaucoup plus que dire que les
discussions étaient à beaucoup d'
ingérence je ne vois pas d'ingérence
dans ce qu'a dit le président macron
bien au contraire
et quant au gouvernement algérien c'est
aux algériens de le décider s'il décide
qu'il n'est pas légitime qui change de
gouvernement mais c'est pas la france de
s'en occuper et la vitrine n'a pas
soutenu son président illégitime tout
simplement vers cette maison on a bien
compris vos d'un point de vue et c'est
ça qui est intéressant puisque c'était
en face à face donc merci à vous à 20
soit de baba aïssa vice présidente de
l'adar général dominique trinquant
d'avoir été avec nous en direct sur rt
france merci à vous deux
au burkina faso à présent les opérations
de dépouillement ont démarré le pays
voté hier faut élire son président et
ses députés un premier tour de scrutin
des élections dans un contexte politique
et sécuritaire tendu selon la commission
électorale entre 300 et 350 mille
personnes n'ont pas pu voter en raison
de l'insécurité liée au risque d'attaqué
alice opposition elle redoute des
fraudes massives
françois tisci beach dès la nuit tombée
dans ce centre de dépouillement de la
capitale les conteurs de voix se met au
travail
toute la journée de dimanche quelques
six millions et demi de burkinabés
étaient appelés à voter pour leur futur
président et des députés un scrutin
déroulée dans un calme relatif dans les
grosses villes mais tendue dans les
régions du nord et de l'est où les
attaques jihadistes sont nombreuses des
bureaux de vote ont même dû fermer sous
la menace d'hommes armés alors que
d'autres n'ont même pas pu ouvrir lors
du vote d'aujourd'hui deux bureaux de
vote ont fermé dans l'est du pays près
de pâma car des rumeurs d'attac leur
sont parvenues kalkar leur a dit que si
les élections se poursuivaient ils
seraient attaqués c'est pourquoi ces
bureaux de vote ont été fermés et à
ouagadougou également deux bureaux de
vote ont été fermés
au total selon la commission électorale
autour de 300 à 350 milles personnes
n'ont pas pu voter en raison des menaces
sécuritaires
le président sortant roch marc christian
kaboré et l'ue en 2015 fait figure de
favori mais l'opposition fait monter la
pression
elles dénoncent des risques de fraudes
et menace de ne pas reconnaître les
résultats
tout se fait là nous interpelle c'est
pour ça que nous avons décidé depuis
hier de porter plainte auprès du
procureur du faso
mais nous connaissons bien la lenteur de
nos institutions judiciaires ce que l'on
veut ce n'est pas d'attendre deux
semaines soit souvent la plus faible
pour trancher
nous on veut que les choses ont changé
de domaine et ça c'est vous ne vous
trouvez votre vigilance qui va nous
aider à faire cela des allégations
réfutées par le parti présidentiel qui
affirme ne pas avoir besoin d'une
quelconque fraude pour gagner les
élections
environ dix mille six cent soixante
observateurs nationaux et internationaux
étaient déployés dans le pays afin de
s'assurer du bon déroulement du scrutin
les résultats quant à eux sont attendus
sous 7 jours et pour en parler nous
sommes avec un simili nabaloum
secrétaire général de la section france
du mouvement du peuple pour le progrès
et un bon soir
d'être avec nous en direct sur arte
france le climat sécuritaire actuelle
est ce qui va empêcher selon vous la
bonne tenue du scrutin au burkina faso
oui je salue dans un premier temps la
mesure qui a été tenue parce que c'était
pas évident et beaucoup de sous sur ce
qui s'était passé mais je salue une
opportunité et je salue aussi la
sensibilité du peuple burkinabè et sur
un pacte et les autorités qui ont tué la
sculpture à ce que cette élection ait
lieu
notre site est évident mais clairement y
at il eu un empêchement de cette
élection raison de ce climat sécuritaire
selon vous ben laden pays où il ya
depuis cinq à yakhya que les attentats
se sont multipliés
de gauche à droite et d'ailleurs
l'opposition douter que ces élections
aient lieu
c'est du parti et le pédant l'autre
martissant favori qui a tenu parole et
koutoukou de faut que ces élections
aient lieu parce que le burkina n'est
pas le premier pays à être attaqué il y
avait bien eu des santons mali mais on a
vu que l'on met le bois lui aussi laissé
les élections ont bel et bien eu lieu
qui est alors qu bourquin s'était c'est
moins pire on m'a dit vous êtes plutôt
satisfait du climat dans lequel elles se
sont tenues au oui je suis tout à fait
satisfait puisque tout vent l'a pu voter
sauf quelques parties du pays qui n'ont
pas pu voter mais c'était simple et
visible et d'ailleurs je plus que c'est
assez mineures vous êtes secrétaire
général du mp on le disait quel est
selon vous le bilan du président sortant
roche marc christian kaboré qui lui
permettra d'ailleurs d'être élu pour un
second mandat
ben le blizzard de chiyah sait bien que
la tête à deux pas bien placé pour le
dire
as grandi à qui personne parce que je
fis le secteur là du parti au pouvoir
mais je pense que les résultats qui vont
tomber c'est le cas que vous lirez des
résultats 6
les réalités du pays de l'or perdu plus
de 4 à 6 ans que paul et qu'il a promis
dans son programme dès 2015 a été
satisfait à si ma mémoire est bonne la
80e à 80 pour ça et le peuple voulant
dire les résultats puisqu'on attend le
lutin d'anciper s'il est élu quelle sera
sa priorité selon vous et bien entendu
et que si vous combinez qu'est ce que
nous avons commencé tard pas parce le
débat c'est à dire que la sécurité la
supplie t sur le premier et deuxième à
la santé est troisième à la vie sociale
et la paix sociale la paix en tout cas
pour beaucoup la réconciliation
nationale au burkina faso passe par le
retour de l'ancien président blaise
compaore est ce que c'est votre position
également pour le pense et je prie je
crois que le pays n'aura pas quitté la
table et c'est des apologies là dessus
personne n'a plus aucun bruit et de
l'intérêt chez lui mais comme nous
sommes en démocratie
en démocratie il faut passer par tous
les chemins michel blaise comparé bien
le plaider a été bien le présent d'une
façon bale en a 27 ans donc il n'ya pas
de raison que quelqu'un de la paix est
l'intergiciel moi si je rentre je suis
cela ils passent la part d'avoir normale
comme tout le monde ça t'a dit qu'il va
passer par la justice
il ira aussi à la jarne si l'agenda
midelt et rouge et qui truquent
messieurs comprennent allen dans le
prochain
meichtry n'a pas des charges tout ça
c'est comme chez nous aujourd'hui
ou quel est à votre souhait le plus cher
pour votre pays c'est à dire qu'est ce
que vous espérez qu'est ce que vous
espérez de cette élection
aujourd'hui clairement bas concernant
les actions je pense que le burkina a
toujours été un exemple
et moi je pense que c'est bien déroulée
puisque les observateurs de la cedeao
l'ont bien c'est le bandit aujourd'hui
tout s'est bien déroulé donc moi je ne
vois pas
dans le tram qui peut être tu puisses 10
à cette élection
merci beaucoup aussi bien nabaloum
d'avoir été avec nous en direct sur rt
france
restez avec nous c'est la fin de cette
émission se retrouve dans quelques
minutes pour 1 point complet sur
l'actualité
[Musique]
il
oui
[Musique]